[Music]
today is gonna be a big day because I am
getting surgery and I am getting a an
implant type of surgery done for my
tooth here I have if you don't know if
you didn't know I actually have a fake
tooth this fake tooth here is not an
implant it is a bridge
fake tooth over the gap of where my
missing tooth is I'm also driving right
now because I'm super late to my
appointment if I'm missing tooth
I mean my body was missing this tooth to
begin with I never had this to Sh since
I was born so by the time I lost my baby
tooth that was there there was no adult
tooth to grow into its place so it
wasn't that that I had it and lost it
it's just I never had it to begin with
so now I am on the way I'm actually kind
of nervous because I you know what I
don't really do the surgeries too often
not that I you know I don't think anyone
really wants to do surgery I don't think
I've ever gone on earth and
and the wisdom teeth pulling out other
than that I think that's it so this
would be my second surgery and yeah for
me growing up surgery's always got this
connotation of pain and and scary you're
going under the knife that phrase is
scary sounding you're going under the
knife I guess I'm just not really not
looking forward to the whole healing
process cause ruby healing they think
I've researched and then the dental
office dr. McKee's shout out to him he
actually passed up my tooth here I'm
going right back to him because he's so
good with cosmetic dental surgery that I
trust him to do this to do this for me
and they say they'll take about two to
four weeks
our recovery depending on the person
depending on the patient's so praying
I'm hoping that I am going to be the in
the two week category
but I guess worst comes to worst I'll
take a whole month to heal yeah with
that said that just means that's a whole
I'm not eating whatever I
needing to baby the the eating process
what not and also these that did say the
tooth the first two three days is
probably the rough is in terms of
swelling and like you're just gonna we
want to eat things out of straw so
that's gonna be the next 2-3 days for me
and I went out with the bang yesterday
with eating lots of crap different
things nothing that works fast yeah
[Music]
and I'm told not to mess with it too
much
my lips are really really numb so I
can't talk very well either
that's they're gonna put a new
temporaries youth in now Jonah hunter
walk around like an egg dish all day
[Music]
alright I just got home from the
doctor's office and oh yeah shout out
from dr. Madani ma'am if you ever want
to get a cosmetic or anti-aging
dentistry done definitely hit up this
number I'm checking out dr. moonda he so
I just got back got off the phone TIFF
and she is that the out-of-pocket cash
shoot so I'm home alone TIFF feels
really bad she sure they wanted to be
home to help nurse me but I was like you
know honestly it's not that big of a
deal and have a lazy lip right now feel
like I got punched in the mouth so it
took a little like it's not working
properly or something I'm all good up
here didn't put me to sleep or anything
it just numb my mouth and they went at
it so I was pretty pretty fun you get to
feel every emotion or doing and they
told me afterwards cuz like I was trying
to film it I don't know if I even got
the footage properly they had
cut up my gums and created a flap so
they've peeled my entire gum back to
show like to see all the teeth that doll
the bone and stuff so they could see how
much bone there is to work with in terms
of putting the implant in and so
originally it was to be an implant was
done today wait for the implant to heal
and the site to heal and then we'll put
the crown in which is their their term
for the actual tooth the fake tooth of
the pudding but today they found out
that my since I've never had our tooth
there there's just there is no support
like so little support I mean I told you
guys like I've watched other dentists
and like they always say oh we can't do
it we can't do it so they found out they
can't do it today
and so what they did is they put like
bone they like like I was watching them
do it and it's like the pack was like a
powdery stuff and they just scooped it
into my to hold the cavity that that's
there and they're trying to create a
foundation for it so they put fake bone
in my jaw so that's kind of cool so
we're gonna wait for that to heal next
time I'll do the implant and then time
after that it'll be the crown so this
whole procedure I'm getting this tooth
fixed
it's about a year's time table and they
say they'll take about two to four weeks
to four weeks so it's a lot longer than
I thought it would be but it's cool
anyways they gave me a really cool bag
do it dr. Madani office is always really
good about giving you waters and
mouthwash and stuff but this is tailored
out specifically for what I need this
time around which is like ice packs and
stuff but they always give me they have
to so many toothbrushes and and
mouthwash is fun them it's kind of it's
kind of funny and ah yeah money I don't
know I showed you guys let's see I can
do this and it looks like right now the
pain is starting to kick in as well I
can feel the anesthesia starting to wear
off so oh yeah it's gonna be fun the
next three days
think I'm just gonna order some joke and
some aka kanji I have a cooking video
and go check out how I make my kanji but
I'm not making country today I'm gonna
order it and because I lived in the six
to six we have a lot of Chinese
restaurants I make kanji
[Music]
try not to burn myself when I'm eating
this yeah I just recently went up to the
mirror and looked in my eye my
reflection and there's a big pool of
blood at the bottom of my mouth it's
gonna be kanji mixed with my own blood
just got back home from picking up the
boy yeah man how was school it was good
yeah yeah nice you learning some
advanced stuff on your way to becoming
the astronaut that you want to be yeah
yeah no what are you guys learning now
like condensation evaporation so he's
talking gibberish to me now was I don't
remember any of that stuff from school
barely well I actually learned it like
in second grade but we're doing getting
word bats yeah you're getting like a
less less glossed over version of the
same topics yeah I just got back from
the yeah got medicines more medicine I
have to be on ibuprofen and tie advanced
extra strength tylenol at the same time
which is pretty pretty gnarly I would
say and coming home staring at this
makes me very very tired because it's
just a lot of clutter
people want keeping up with our vlogs we
have been on the go with trying to get
rid of clutter the past this past week
and we've cleared out our garage which
looks immaculate now and we're gonna
slowly get rid of everything including
these couches as well couches shelf I
think Jess called dibs on that Tiff's
mom wants that but we got to get rid of
these couches cuz none of these couches
are gonna fit in our new house and I
think just calling me our Emperor's
owner she texted me mommy's heading home
yay my nurses coming home
my nurses coming home I have to do this
went grocery shopping got some always
looks like brains
I don't like brains got some beef Isaac
wants lunch tomorrow has requested to
have pasta so we make them pasta tonight
I've had this ice cream in here for so
long and I just never got around to
eating it because I'm trying to be
expanded diet be a good boy
heels left over from the holidays but
then the doctor today was telling me
that I should you ice cream because it's
good for open sores in the mountains or
whatever
given my mouth situation I'm not trying
to open it too much I'm not trying to
you know chew on hard to eat foods vegan
protein shake trying to stay away from
the dairy I don't know and here all
people are actually somewhat intolerant
to mute milk limit my dairy intake for
the most part I'm up in my oatmeal
intake I guess now because I've loaded
up on two different types of milks and
I'm kind of curious as to which one
tastes better I got oh no and I got soy
milk berna best Chinese boy I know what
soy milk tastes like I know how soy milk
affects the flavors of everything that
you do with it so it was a safer bet
I've always been using soy milk forever
since oat milk caught on so likes it
matcha which is now Jumba matcha I need
to make a vlog about that cuz I have so
much footage of like behind the scenes
stuff the big secret from last year that
I like I was working so much on and I
just didn't have time to like I couldn't
really talk about it or share anything
about was Jumba matcha Jumba matcha is a
rebranded version of sip matcha we were
looking at franchise and we couldn't
franchise with the name sit watch it
because a lot of people were saying sip
might be a too simple of the name and we
need to have much more creative name if
you want to do franchising stuff so we
want to avoid like you know future
lawsuits or whatever sip at the time
June B now they were the first they
implemented oat milk on their menu
really
the early on and I was like what I know
that there was such a thing as oat milk
and now fast forward a couple months
from the time that maybe in half a year
since they started having oat milk on
their menu
now here Starbucks has all milk now I
hear like all these other coffee shops
and whatnot has oatmeal yeah Oh milk has
caught on quite a bit
well I'm personally a late adopter oat
milk and oatmeal or soy milk in oatmeal
that's a big question
[Music]
all right my nurse is home finally I
feel good but when I got out of the
doctor thought that I was gonna be with
in a lot of pain and stuff because you
can tell you're like B being lazy how I
talk well it's like a big clump of stuff
right here to a big swollen or whatever
I don't know I feel like I can't really
move my bottom lip right now I was like
I feel like I have a lot of food stuck
right there right now like cotton yeah
swelling the swelling yeah and like the
stitches I have 22 stitches in the mouth
right here so it just yeah just feels
like there's a lot of stuff going on and
I feel like I want to stick my tongue in
there I know it's it's just it hurts so
much
and like it's just I just I just need
some extra kisses now isn't that bad
really did you see the pictures oh yeah
boy you got like nothing and then they
filled it with stuff and then they just
it's pretty crazy
I had an impromptu yoga hot yoga class
with no nice so this is all like I'm
disgusting she let me borrow her you
look nice I don't know I mean like I'm
under this it's all like dried sweat
because she let me borrow her yoga stuff
that sounds great you have like
beautiful smelling sweat so we were just
gonna have lunch and then she's like oh
I forgot it booked a yoga class and I'm
like cool I got class best I'll do it
with you cuz he jumped right in you had
a productive day you just some podcast
and make that bread right and then you
went to go work out it all builds
towards one thing and Megan Megan I
don't know how to say her last name
ring-ring no but she's super cool and
she'd like Mickey's friend mm-hmm and
she's pretty much having all the girls
on her podcast and she just gels really
well what's that like all right one of
those she's she's kinda like us like
we're we just are really open so back to
the game over here I am teaching Isaac
how to play basketball
not by teaching how to play basketball
but by teach him how to play NBA 2k what
we were just saying yes cuz I'm like I'm
trying to focus on our conversation but
to be so little no I'm sorry
good ears hello everyone whose ears go
down yeah when I came home I dropped off
Isaac after school I go grocery shopping
right and when I came back from grocery
shopping like Isaac was like I think so
mrs. mommy really what cuz he was
meowing at the door and stuff and in the
back of my mind I was like he couldn't
be missing me maybe because I'm coming
home he's missing me no he was
I know right now when I got home he was
like trying to like rub his body on my
legs she kind of got in between my legs
and I almost tripped so I can kick them
walk in here walk in here right bye
[Music]